[Music]
and Love by seems to be what caped is
trying to say to Britney Spears he wants
to move to Hawaii I spoke to his
Powerhouse attorney Mark Vincent Kaplan
who says it has been more than a year
since Brittany has seen her son's 17
year old Sean and 16 year old Jaden even
though Kevin has so legal custody we
want mom's consent do you think that
Britney will object Brittany has good
legal counsel I think that she will do
the smart thing and not object because
she's not really exercising any
custodial time with either boys it's not
going to deprive her of any meaningful
time with the boys
any comments uh on Britney you and the
boys
are you guys on speaking terms with her
I don't have anything
Brittany objects he will go to court and
their sons are eager to make the move
sometime in July her relationship with
their sons has been strained for a while
and it all came to a head last September
this is our safe place to you know
process all the emotional trauma that
we've been through that's when Jaden
spoke out against her parenting skills
including all those racy social media
posts
[Music]
if she has to post something
there's a high chance that this has
never gonna really stop Brittany
responded saying quote my love for my
children has no boundaries and it deeply
saddens me I wasn't up to his
expectations of a mother would you hold
it against me Brittany has not commented
on Kevin's request to move but her
husband samusgari has come to her
defense in the wake of several other
reports one claimed Britney has a
fascination with knives and at the end
of the conservatorship it was
recommended to keep them away from her
it was absolutely disgusting and don't
believe what you read online 99 of the
time those are all click baits for you
to click and for them to make money
gotta stop
[Music]
thank you